[Music]
you're listening to
inside the view with michael rosenbaum i
just wanted to do that because it's
halloween you know a month
you know it's my favorite month favorite
time of the year really yeah
it is uh as you can see behind you are
my evil dead poster
lost boys fright night uh the thing
poster behind me that i just watched
last night with the horror zoom group
you know i have a horror zoom group
we watch the fly and then um
so we vote on movies and then so
everybody picks three and then everybody
has to pick
three of other people's choices for
horror movies for that week
so so there's ultimately five weeks in
october
because we kind of used november 30.
whatever it's like we do five weeks
so everybody gets pretty much a movie
that they want to see and um so we had a
pretty good selection but uh last night
was the fly in the thing so i was up to
one i
i just was so happy because i love those
movies they were so good
i haven't seen either yeah well there
you go
but love halloween and uh i hope you
guys listen to last week's episode
because it was uh
incredibly intense and insightful if you
haven't again
go back and listen to sarah edmondson if
you're here for kevin smith great
but uh hopefully if you like this
interview you'll stick around and listen
to other interviews i think
you know you'll dig them um but sarah
vincent you know
allison mack was on smallville with me
and she joined this thing that became
this cult
and uh so he talked about that and this
woman sarah who's really
amazing um talked about getting branded
all this stuff so it was a really
interesting week and it was
you know a lot of press and things like
that and uh
you know it's it's it's nice to hear
from peers and just people around that
shoot you're texting me dude i listen to
that interview it's really good i'm like
well listen can you listen to others can
you subscribe for
[ __ ] sake god damn it i think that's
the thing you know
you know people people listen to the
episode they oh i want to listen to that
person yeah kevin smith fans which is
great
i'm glad you're here uh they might have
just fast forward i don't want to hear
this guy
but uh we had a lot of great stuff to
say on the on the podcast uh just a few
things
if you're here and yet you don't uh
subscribe or you don't uh follow us
on instagram twitter or facebook it's
really easy it's at uh inside of you
podcast on instagram and facebook at
insideyoupod
on the twitter and uh thank you to
westwood one for their support we joined
forces of westwood one about two months
ago and things are
uh things are going well very happy with
them and they're working hard and uh
so to all the girls and and boys over at
westwood one
i really appreciate you uh you know who
you are
uh also the uh lots of new merch at the
inside of you online store we got new
flip-flops tumblers like badass tumblers
that like you know you could throw off a
building and they'd still be all right
tank tops and mugs autograph mugs and
wine glasses beach towels all that [ __ ]
uh rosie pants one r-o-s-e-y
pants p-a-n-t-s-1 for 15 off the
inside of you online store just for you
guys listening today
also stage it is next weekend rob and i
are singing some tunes it's a halloween
special uh we're gonna be dressed up
we're gonna dress up we got some i'm
decorating the downstairs
um we're gonna play some music we might
play monster mash
some things like that uh we're excited
about it we're working on the album
and uh great prizes like zoom's winner
gets uh
their choice of a song that we'll play
will videotape and send it back to you
you get a zoom anybody who bids over
it's 3 500 notes whatever that is uh get
an automatic zoom
from um uh from us after the show so
uh thank you for listening thank you for
the continuous we got some great guys in
fact next week's guest
it's uh it's gonna be a big one i'm not
saying who it is i'm not saying what
happened but
uh this person's coming on here to
exclusively tell us some
some good news or bad news or bad and
good news but
whatever whatever's newsworthy breaking
news breaking news and uh it's nice when
people you really respect and admire and
just uh
you know fans of the podcast uh they
they call you and they say i want to
come on and talk about something and
you're like
really so that's cool uh reminding you
all to vote
whoever you vote for it's just important
that your voice gets heard and you know
there's nothing worse than people
sitting at home going
bitching about everything and not doing
anything about it said you know what you
can't [ __ ]
if you hate what's going on or if you
hate the current president or if you
hate
biden or if you and you don't vote it's
like just shut up then
vote down ballot your community is
important too just zip it up man
just do do all the voting yeah i'm
voting i voted
you voted i voted already yeah so just
vote whoever you vote for i i love you i
don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] phone all right let's get inside
this guy it's funny because i didn't
think he'd like me for a while because
you know uh we talked about it because i
left smallville he says
i left smallville but i i did leave
smallville but it was there was reasons
and
you know my contract ended but we talk
about a lot of stuff we talk about some
stuff that i don't think he's ever
talked about
um and uh i really found him interesting
and you know i feel like i
i i have a new friend a lot of times i
interview someone i'm like it goes well
and i just feel like there's a
connection and that does happen but
with kevin smith i felt like um i just
we i felt like we liked each other he
was texting me after he's like
on the show you'll hear him anytime you
want me back and if you guys want him
back
listen to this tell me what you think
please subscribe and
uh email all your friends the links and
uh spotify apple
podcasts of course uh youtube we're all
over youtube where you can watch these
videos that ryan edits that are
really well edited and fun to watch so
check that out and let's get inside
of kevin smith it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
how are you how are you i'm doing all
right you look great
oh i'm trying to stay alive um what
so is that a jerk poster behind you well
hell yeah signed by steve martin
the [ __ ] how well i did a movie called
uh
bringing down the house yeah yeah yeah
he was i wore a bad wig in it because i
was bald from smallville
but he was so awesome man i've talked
about it before but
i was at lunch sitting at a table and
he'd come over is this seat taken
and he'd sit right next to me and tell
me about smallville
so at the end i brought him a bunch of
tapes that's pretty good
steve i'd never done a steve martin it
was just the essence of a steve martin
but um i brought that poster in the last
day i was done i go hey man i'm like
that i don't know
most actors don't i talk about this by
the way to every guest and i'm like
can you sign this poster for me man is
it of cour
come on in and he played some banjo in
his trailer and he was just a delight
man
you got to hear him play banjo update
yeah have you met him never
i saw him years ago the montreal film
festival and he was getting the same
year
he was there with a movie called the
simple twist of fate
and which was kind of a remake of silas
marner if i remember correctly
and he you know they like festivals when
when
somebody's in town they're like we're
gonna give you a lifetime achievement
award
so they gave him a lifetime achievement
award or something like that and
they had the press conference in a mall
so he was like in front of the fountains
and [ __ ] they had press comments so
people in the mall were watching
and we didn't know there was breakfast
conference going on me and moshe were
just crossing through the mall
and all of a sudden we saw like they
were like ladies and gentlemen
and they brought them out and [ __ ] and
he just seemed
so somber like he was so not
you know the dude that we grew up
watching it was so like
um i remember somebody heckled i mean it
wasn't even a heckle barely they were
like steve get a job
and he go you know i'm like uh what's
what comedy gold is gonna come from here
and he was just like thank you that was
it so
i remember thinking early on like comedy
genius but doesn't feel the need to
turn it on or keep it on i guess isn't
that's a rarity that you could have that
that strength or i guess steve martin
but like you know
i couldn't i'm not that reserved i
couldn't if someone i i don't imagine
myself with an audience no matter how
sad i was or how
sombrero was i'd have to turn it on but
he could get away with it but like i
even like
were you like this is uncomfortable it
wasn't that i was uncomfortable but i
was just like oh my god like this is the
first time i'd ever seen
a version of the polyache or you know
[ __ ] syndrome where
the funniest guy is maybe not you know
feeling all that funny all the time and
i'm certainly not like saying he was
[ __ ] pressed
like he was just like you know and again
i wasn't engaged with him it was from
the
second floor looking down but it was
not like what i assumed
as steve martin anything would be like
if he has
you know 200 people staring at him i
just assume
like every entertainer you know you turn
it on instincts kick in
so now it could be that he was there
with a simple twist of fate which was
more of a dramatic film and stuff and it
could be that he was like getting
lifetime achievement or something but
yeah it was it was i'll never i mean to
this day whenever i think of steve
martin up until that moment
any time i thought steve martin i was
like oh all of me the jerk
comic genius yeah and wild and crazy guy
the album which i listened to
incessantly in the 70s
and then every you know steve martin
thought i have after that is just like
that poor man
he just did not want to be all sitting
in the middle of a mall
and talking about his career well i met
uh jim carrey
it was at a beach house you know the day
he was really nice but again he wasn't
like you know he was like hey there
how are you today alrighty then
he wasn't doing that he was just kind of
like hey how are you okay
and to be fair like i bet you when
people meet us
like you know you don't give them
[ __ ] lex and i don't give them silent
bob but like
these cats are too larger than life
right like you know they've played roles
in movies and
those those two roles that i mentioned
are famous roles and [ __ ] like that
we're not known for going around doing
our thing in public i especially don't
shut up like that's that's the
characters and i'm not that smart
so i don't so when i talk people aren't
going well
he didn't use the word colloquialism you
know
we're also like [ __ ] sinister like
that guy knows all the angles and [ __ ]
dude i think you know i i'm not talking
this is about you i'm not talking about
me but i just remember when i got the
role
every one of my friends my friend matt i
had a little gathering and celebratory
thing and
everybody's laughing and matt's got his
pants down he's got this lex luther
doll shoved in his ass and it kind of it
was humbling but i was like ugh
they just don't buy they're like you
dude they're going to fire you you're
not lex luthor i'm like
i could i'm an actor i could do this
and it just was like you know it was it
was it was definitely daunting it was
definitely a scary time
what have you done right before that
where they tapped you i know i know
this is more about me than you but i'm
still fascinated because
that's my world so you're talking about
a show who is it miles and
alan miles al goff miles more and miles
yeah
still to this day one of the only
regrets i've ever had in my career
and some people would be like jersey
girl [ __ ] yoga hosers the list is
long
the only regret one of the only regrets
i have in my career
is um they sent me
like a faxed letter that's how far back
this goes oh yeah
when they were working on on small bill
gohan and milar
and they were like hey man like
come out and direct one of these and
that was when i was like i just directed
what i write i could never direct
somebody else's script that's insane
so i never went and muse jason
as you well know loves smallville he
loved it when it was happening
he still [ __ ] loves it to this day so
the notion of like
now having done like cw shows
i'm like oh my god like i could have
gotten started on that
way earlier like a decade maybe more
earlier than like when i finally
directed a flash
and it honestly might have changed the
course of my career
not that i'm like oh i missed out on it
but like if you're directing
like commercial tv and and you know it's
as i
found with cw it's a wonderful
little environment where nobody's like
you can only uh
you can only achieve you can't really
fail in that environment they won't let
you make a bad show because they make
one every week
right so they know how to do it right so
the only
only good things ever came from like
directing those shows like
you know especially it was coming in the
wake of like yoga hosers and so a lot of
people were unkind
so that first flash episode i did people
were just like hey
he [ __ ] seems to know what he's doing
or something like that welcoming they
were welcoming
they were and also appreciative of like
you know me the whole time going it
wasn't me
zach stets wrote an amazing script i
just like brought it to [ __ ] life as
best i could but the crew does it every
week i'm the only thing that was
different this week
so trust me it's not like necessarily
just me but i realized if i had done
smallville that would have started
10 to 15 years earlier wow and who knows
like i might be directing [ __ ]
superhero movies right now
which is not something that i ever
aspired to
or dreamed about like a lot of people
always like when you're gonna make a
marvel movie i'm like
number one they're too smart to give me
money number two
that that job is too big for the likes
of me
like the cw shows i'm sure it was this
way on uh and probably less
when you guys were doing small though
what were your episodes like six day
weeks five day weeks
ten we had eight days on smallville we
had was a one hour and it was like all
these
luxurious but it was these special
effects that they hadn't really done it
was very
you know it was it was brand new it was
uh it was just it just changed the game
in a lot of ways for tv and
so we had eight days of episodes and
then two four
additional like you know stunts and all
that stuff so they were like yeah it was
we were up there ten months a year
but you're right though when you said uh
it is a family i'm not saying anybody
could direct cheating because
it's not true yeah i personally believe
anyone could direct tv if if as long as
you walk on
maybe not a pilot maybe not season one
but if you walk onto a season two set
of a show that's up and running
everybody knows what the [ __ ] they're
doing
like anybody can direct really it's just
a matter of going action and cut
everyone else does their jobs really
well like i
rarely ever walked over if ever to give
somebody
like directing tip or acting tips like
my direction like we'd roll a take and
then i'd go over and be like that's
[ __ ] awesome and then i go back to
the chair
and you give presents i heard like lots
of things where like you're the best guy
on set you'll give presents to people
you'll give
but like but i think that's also part
it's fun but you're
look you're i like the self-deprecation
we i do it
but like you know what you're doing
you've done some great things
just because you think you have done
some we've all done oh well
look at this this got me attention and
then i did this
and then we have this that didn't do
well or bombed i always say
if somebody has one hit movie they've
got one hit movie
if they've got one thing that i liked i
go they're great i don't care if they
have 10 pieces of [ __ ]
i remember before i had a career back
when i was just like a film enthusiast
you know somebody that dreamed about
making movies um you know spike lee
had made he started with she's got to
have it then he did school days and his
third film
was do the right thing and do the right
thing is an astounding achievement
that's still
one of my five favorite films of all
time and still holds up today even more
now today oddly enough than than when
they made the movie or
it's just as relevant today as in 1989
which is a sad statement on the country
so i love that movie um a couple years
later man like
he did something maybe it was girl six
or something that a bunch of people were
kind of like crapping on
and my whole thing was like hey man that
dude made do the right thing
like he gets a pass forever
right and right then i had a career
thankfully one day i heard somebody in
the depths of my career when i was doing
[ __ ] nobody liked
i heard somebody go like well at least
he made clerks and i was like yes
the do the right thing defense it's
gonna come in my favor as well
but that's a healthy way to look at it
and we and of course when the shit's
piling up
and we're bombing and we're like you
know well
it's it's how you look at it we look at
it differently then you're probably not
as
optimistic were you you probably were
like you hit brock
i was terrified that like look the first
movie we made was clerks
and i'll be the first to tell you we
were insanely overpraised we were in
flavor of the year
not even just the month and people said
such nice things about that moving stuff
mall rats polar opposite experience
a bunch of i mean now people really like
the movie it's aged well but when it
came out critics like [ __ ] in its mouth
it did no money at the box office the
poster which
drew struzant painted and is [ __ ]
classic as far as i'm concerned
was confusing to people because they
were like is this a magazine like it
looked like the cover of a comic book
but you know most people didn't get that
comical culture wasn't [ __ ] that big
at that time and [ __ ]
so i think to a lot of people like oh
this must be a new magazine coming out
called mall rats or something like that
so like everything that could have went
wrong went wrong and i remember being
like
we're over you know there was a moment i
was so early in my career
i was like universal gave us five
million to make this movie it only made
two million do i owe them three million
dollars because i got that kind of
[ __ ] scratch
so that's an instance of me going like
we're [ __ ]
finished like you could find interviews
from me with me at that time
like there's a premier magazine quote
where you know i was like um
i've spent the summer like uh or i've
spent the last two weeks because i guess
mall rats came out like in the beginning
of the
fall or something like that and i said i
spent the last two weeks
uh curled up in the fetal position in a
dark bedroom
with a stack of bad reviews in one hand
and a shotgun in the other and stuff
and um you know it seemed like
i'm done you know chasing amy was a hail
mary for me because i was like
we're finished like [ __ ] nobody's
gonna hire me that was it one hit wonder
the sophomore jinx was the most
terrifying thing in the world
to young filmmakers first-time
filmmakers man if you were lucky enough
to get attention for your first film
then you had to run the gauntlet of what
people would make of your second film
and in my case
people made nothing of it they were like
oh i remember the reviews
like uh what's his name kenny duran said
in the la times he goes
if if uh afi
or sundance ever offer a course on what
not to do as a second feature
mall rat should be at the heart of the
curriculum that was the nicest part of
it like all the reviews were very
dismissive and the general tone was we
put this guy here with clerks this is
the [ __ ] he makes [ __ ] these sundance
kids
like give them no money or whatever so i
believe believe haunted me forever
for about 10 years then 10 years into my
career 10 years after mall rats
suddenly like everything changed
suddenly people had watched it on home
video or on hbo or
for years and i was the one i always
remember that it flopped and i would say
that to people i was like oh my god that
movie tech where you know people go i
love mall rats i'd be like where were
you
in 95 we could have used your helpers
it couldn't have tanked it can't be no
way it's got to be a huge box office
success because i have it on dvd and i'm
like
those two things are not necessarily
equitable
so you realize you're the one that
carries around the failure
like you wear you know just like jacob
marley we wear the chains we forge in
light
ain't nobody out there still remembers
that [ __ ] mall rats tank
except me maybe some i'm not even anyone
at universal anymore they're all [ __ ]
gone at this point and
changed so many times so there was a
time i was terrified and then
10 years later and even up till this
moment in time
mall rats is like one of the movie oddly
the movie that almost killed my career
is the one that has kept it [ __ ]
buoyed isn't that something
like stan lee reading the script from
all rats and
captain marvel with you know was doing
his lines out loud
was like everything that to me was the
moment where i was like you know what
because i remember like being there when
people were like you shouldn't have done
that
maybe you shouldn't have made that book
and [ __ ] that's the worst thing in the
world to hear right
like oh man second guessing your
artistic statement your statement
your you know uh testimony if you will
but like
when stan lee you know was was doing the
line you know trust me true believer
in captain marvel that for me was
graduation day where i'm like
this [ __ ] movie that everyone
left for dead in the goddamn [ __ ]
hot sun and [ __ ] survived and like
you know lives and has this weird
[ __ ] modicum of respect to it and
[ __ ] so
you never know what the thing's gonna be
but i
i do often wonder if i had jumped into
smallville like when
they had written me that facts
what would the career look like today
probably the same because like
i'm overly dedicated to making kevin
smith movies because
they got a lot of people make those
comic book movies ain't nobody wants to
make kevin smith's movie but kevin smith
so i i often feel like i would have
gravitated
this way like there have been there were
a lot of opportunities to do something
better
different than what people assume i've
done with my career like i remember at
one point they were like you direct
goodwill hunting
and you know i was like i love this
[ __ ] script but
honestly i will turn to ben and matt
every [ __ ] scene and be like what'd
you see when he wrote this all right
let's just shoot that
because back then i was like i'm a
writer
director capital w and all the way
through
lowercase d all the way through i fancy
myself more a writer than a director and
still kind of do
to this day but you do anything for
[ __ ] 26 years
even if you do it haphazardly you'd wind
up getting better at it you know like so
i have gotten kind of better with age
which is nice
yeah but it's never never been my thing
the writing is always the more important
but do you feel like now
you really think because we could sit
there and tell ourselves like i don't
even read reviews i don't give a [ __ ]
is there a point in your life and when
was it where you just were like
hey man i'm just gonna do what i do i'm
gonna do what i do i'm gonna get things
made because i love movies i'm gonna get
people people will like them or they
won't i
can't i can't be happy or unhappy based
on
an outcome of uh the box office it's a
great question
and and to throw out the disclaimer
before i head into it one night
these are [ __ ] first world problems
kids
like when when you've gotten to a place
that you're trying to get to
um that's everything and you never have
any right
to [ __ ] that being said maintaining
that
is far more difficult nobody tells you
that when you start out you know because
you're so full piss of vinegar you're
like i just want to express myself i'll
be a
director i won't be an actor or whatever
[ __ ] nobody tells you like
if you're lucky enough to get picked
where they put your [ __ ]
you know in front of the public then you
got to do it again
then you gotta do it again then you
gotta do it again you gotta keep doing
it until you drop
[ __ ] dead and you know oh or you
you get kicked out the club so it's like
anyone comes up with a magic trick is an
amazing thing you know slight of hand
and [ __ ] like you know [ __ ]
like jimmy at a party i'm like what's
that and they pull a porter out
here clerks is me pulling a quarter out
from behind somebody's here they're like
oh that's clever well done
and i thought that would have been it
like once i made one of those then you
know [ __ ]
hey there's my magic trick but then you
know they're like all right what's next
and for the
last 26 years they've been going like
what's next so if i want to stay in the
game
you got to keep making [ __ ] you got to
maintain you've got to have longevity
and that's the thing nobody prepares you
for nobody tells you like hey man
how long do you want to be in this
[ __ ] you know i wish my [ __ ] was like
a tv season
where i broke it up in the seasons where
i'm like you know after 10 seasons i'm
out or something like that
but with no defined
exit point because i don't even have a
defined exit point based on whether the
movies did good or bad because at the
end of the day i can just shoot a lower
budget movie
you know like as was the case with chase
amy moratz came out didn't do well
cost 5 million to make didn't do well we
went and made chase gaming for 250 grand
that went on to make like 12 million so
i've you know i'm not like chris nolan
in many [ __ ] ways any critic will
tell you but one of those ways is like
chris is always like we need as much
money as possible to do this practically
and do it right because cinema is
forever chip
and i'm the guy coming from indie film
who's just like
that's good enough that's that'll get
the job done good enough
is the only way i've gotten this far in
my career if i was striving for
perfection
you never even want to see in clerks for
christ's sake fluid clerks it's
absolutely imperfect
but my whole career was predicated on an
absolutely imperfect sloppy first effort
so what did that teach me for the next
10 years of my career i was like
doesn't have to be better than clerks
like if they'll sit through clerks
they'll watch this and because of that i
never really pushed myself
or have pushed myself every once in a
while there's like tusk or some sort of
[ __ ] but like
visually speaking i kept [ __ ] real
[ __ ] simple it was only
after directing as many years as i have
where you're just like well maybe i can
maybe i can grow maybe i could try this
i've been around long enough like
and i'm not this is not i don't want
them to just be misread as like i'm
bored i [ __ ] love
what i do for a living but at a certain
point and it's like you know
after the first five movies every
movie's a joy to make don't get me wrong
but after the first five movies it's
like i i know what the experience of
movie making is that's why when
podcasting
happened like i've been podcasting for
13 years now we started 2007.
because that was an art form that was
like what
like i don't need millions of dollars i
can just i could [ __ ] invite my
friends over and sit in my office and
smoke weed and chit-chat
that's the art form for me so like that
you know
even though at a point where i was like
ah
you know movies like there was a point
where i retired i literally retired
after like red state i was like i'm done
like this is it this last movie i made
i'm good i'll buy it
and you really believed that you were
done you were like i'm [ __ ] this
i did not even in a [ __ ] this kind of
way but i'm just like
you know i got nothing left to say that
was my point i was like you know let a
young person
say some [ __ ] i don't really have that
much you've seen every trick i can do
red state felt like a high water mark
where i'm like this don't look like
nothing i've ever done before if i took
my name off that movie
a single [ __ ] in the world
including my own mother would know that
i made that boot so at that point i felt
like you know what
this is my film school this is my
masterpiece and i don't mean masterpiece
like this is brilliant like a nolan
movie
i mean like you know i was an apprentice
for a [ __ ] decade or more
and finally i was like i'm going to
present my masterpiece to see if i can
go up the next level that's how it
worked you had an apprentice working
under a master artist
and then one day the apprentice would be
like
i made my piece my masterpiece and this
for you to judge and tell me whether i
can ascend or not
and that's what red state felt like to
me interestingly enough
so did jay and sam and bob reboot but
red state when i felt like you know what
this is it like i've shown that i've
learned how to do this the guy who made
clerks which
is a fun movie to watch or listen to but
like tough to look at because it looks
like a shot through a glass of milk
learned how to shoot a movie good for
him and i felt like that's the time
to get out get out while you're feeling
good so for three years
all i did was podcast tour like
just do live shows i wrote the book we
see you know we had comic book men the
tv show going on
but i was convinced that i was done with
film steve soderbergh said he was going
to retire and i'm like he's way better
than me at the job
this is what people this is what
everybody's doing now we're quitting
this is what we do and quentin has also
talked about i said quitting
not quitting i said quitting
is also a factor because he talked about
i'm only making 10 and getting the [ __ ]
out now i remember he said to me at one
point
he was like directing is a young man's
game he said directing isn't for old
people man you know
no such thing as a really good old
director he said it belongs to young
people
and i was like well he's [ __ ] one of
the smartest people i met in this
business in terms of like
great at what he does he must know a
thing or two about a thing or two
so there was a moment where i was like
i'm i'm done
and then it was through podcasting
through an episode of smodcast where me
and moser wound up talking about this
weird walrus story
that suddenly i was like oh like i would
like to
see this movie you could hear it on uh
smodcast episode 259
me and moser sitting there building a
fake movie by accident
same way like we would always [ __ ]
around with a podcast but you hear me
get serious about it moser [ __ ]
around and me going like this could be a
legit good movie man
and then i was like hashtag on twitter
like you think i should make this is a
movie walrus yes you think a stupid idea
walrus no and the next morning sea of
walrus yes
one walrus know and the one walrus know
said
i only said walrus no because i want to
support the democratic process i'm
really walrus yes
i should write this [ __ ] script and
you know you should never ask the
internet
what you should do they'll all it's not
like they're looking out for your best
interest
but in this case it was in my best
interest like you know suddenly
i i realized i got a chance here with my
audience
they heard the initial idea how often
does that happen when a
[ __ ] is there for the moment of
inspiration yeah generally most people
see
the end product like here's the movie
here's the tv show here's the song once
it's all produced
but they were there when i was like
wouldn't it be great if we made a movie
about a guy who turns another guy into a
walrus
so i felt like if i could bring that
[ __ ] to life
in front of the audience like the
audience of smodcast now that they've
heard the idea
i could take this [ __ ] from cradle to
grave and show them the entire
filmmaking process not just like hey
surprise i'm making a clerk sequel
just like you heard about this walrus
thing you wanted to see it i want to see
it
so i'm going to open source this [ __ ]
and you're going to see
how a stupid-ass [ __ ] idea can become
a movie and if i could do that with this
idea
then you should be able to do it with
your ideas and stuff so that
fired me up again and when i came back
to filmmaking
i didn't care about the things i used to
care about i didn't care about reviews i
didn't care about box office
and i'm not to say like [ __ ] all those
people it's just it was no longer the
primary concern i've been in the game
long enough to know that like what
really matters
is longevity like just like when marat's
came out and flopped
you know if that was the end of the
story then the lesson i would have
learned is like be careful
watch your step don't make bad movies or
whatever the [ __ ]
but as it turns out it wasn't a bad
movie to a bunch of people who embraced
it and now that movie is like one of the
top favorites of all the movies i've
ever [ __ ] done and stuff
so at that point you're like i guess if
i could just stick around
longevity will like you know if i'm here
this long
the point we were doing tusks like i was
like i've been here doing this job for
nearly
20 [ __ ] years like from day one of
being
you know and making movies being in the
public got being on the internet mostly
because we were on
online from like 1995 forward
um for viewersfeud.com was like the
website we opened at the tail end of 95.
so i was interacting with the audience
like from malt the end of maul rat's
fault so
after you know you do that for a bunch
of years like
two decades and stuff like that there's
not a single [ __ ] day goes by
don't get me wrong lots of love people
say wonderful things about you all the
[ __ ] you want to hear
you'll see but also all the [ __ ] you
secretly dread
someone will ever say also gets written
so for the last like 20 years i've been
like
you know just tempered in raw [ __ ] like
i've been told every day of my life
professional life by some stranger that
i suck
at my job that i shouldn't be a director
people have people say that to you
in person never in person i mean very
rarely in person every once in a while
somebody will tell you they don't like
the movie you made but
i can't think of anyone that ever told
me face to face somebody said
somebody said to me once it wasn't he
waited in line at a convention where i
was signing and i was just you know
and he just got up there and he goes
gene hackman's the best lex luthor ever
and i go
yeah i agree and he's like all right
walked off
i was like dude like it's gene hackman
you know what the [ __ ] you know it's
like but
so it's like like what a waste of your
time at a con not your time
that person's time like you're sitting
there anyway and [ __ ]
there's so much to see at a con and they
waited all that time just to get up to
you to be like gene hackman it wasn't
that much time
kevin it was you know my line wasn't
that big at the time i could say it was
but maybe it wasn't as big
how long was the last i don't know i'm
just looking around easily 30 minutes
i've been to a comic book show or two in
my day nobody has a line less than 30
minutes so that [ __ ] probably
waited 30 minutes
just to make that comment i had a dude
come up to me at
wondercon in san francisco
at the um nasal center or something like
that
moscone moscone center i come down this
escalators to go on to the floor as i
hit the floor
a bunch of people come around and like
maybe five to ten
with [ __ ] to sign and stuff and this is
pre
cell phones everywhere so there weren't
a lot of like let's take pictures
there's more can you sign can you sign
so there's this one kid comes up to me
hands me i'll never forget this was so
[ __ ] up
like a free giveaway from the marvel
booth it was like a
daily bugle notepad that had spider-man
on it
so like on one hand you were like why
would the daily bugle put spider-man on
their notepad they hate spider-man but
obviously
this is not an incontinuity prop it's a
free giveaway to comic con and i'm
overthinking
so i take it and i'm signing it and then
the guy goes
i hand it back to him he goes i don't
even know why i asked for this
i don't even like you and i was like
well then you've wasted both of our time
then i headed in then you kind of want
to take it back from him
i mean but at the same time he spent his
time like
to him it was valuable use of his time
to wait just to
cut me down to size and to his credit
you know that was 15 17 years you
remembered it
still remember it man don't know him
don't know his name
he probably forgot the incident
ryan i know it's halloween and i know
there's a lot of uh freaky stories that
we hear
a lot you know and you hear tragic
stories
you know yeah the guy who tried to cross
the train tracks
and his car stalled and he didn't make
it
he didn't look both ways right you
always have those thoughts in your mind
too
you know you're you're at the train
track you're like i just i gotta get
through because i
otherwise i'm gonna be stuck here for 15
minutes i'm done i just i'll be late i
can't
well you stop trains can't
and it can be a little frustrating folks
especially if you're in a hurry
you're running late to find yourself at
a railway crossing
waiting for a train and if the signals
are going in the train's not even there
yet
you may feel a little tempted to try and
sneak across the tracks
don't ever to the naked eye trains often
appear to be further away
and moving slower than they are and they
can't stop quickly
even if the engineer hits the emergency
brake right away it can take a train
over a mile to stop
over a mile to stop and by that time
it's too late
and the result is a potentially deadly
crash
the point is you can't know how quickly
the train will arrive the train can't
stop quickly ryan even if it sees you it
ends in disaster
if the signals are on the train is on
its way and you just need to remember
one thing stop trains
can't inside of you is brought to you by
quip
i mean sometimes i feel like do i even
need to talk about it because people
just love this company
it's so good the quality the products
are so good that they sell themselves so
i think they just humor me
you know they're like i'll let rosenbaum
read a couple spots i love these things
i
i have them upstairs i've been using
they're so affordable
you know you spend so much for an
electric toothbrush these days
it's like you know hundreds and hundreds
of dollars and you're like going really
is this
is this making my teeth better not
really you don't need to spend that much
money to uh you know i think
people try to be fancy and whatever but
uh ryan when's the last time you get
rewarded for brushing your teeth
never never yeah with quips new smart
electric toothbrush good habits can earn
you great perks
like free products gift cards and more
uh
you know what's amazing is uh with the
bluetooth uh
compatibility um they uh
it tells you like how well you're
brushing your teeth how long you're
brushing your teeth how many times
and you get these points and these
points add up for you to get free stuff
i turned into seinfeld i got so excited
what is the deal
there's so many things i could talk
about with quip uh you know i love the
two minute timer
uh with 30 second pulses for a guy to
clean
it's slim sleek lightweight no wires no
bulky chargers that that's a that's a
huge thing for me
you walk into my bathroom there's just
wires everywhere
it's a toothbrush multi-use travel cover
that doubles as a mirror mount for less
clutter eco-friendly solar battery to
power your quip with sunshine
the refresh bag to bring your good oral
care habits
everywhere you go start getting rewards
for brushing your teeth today and go to
get
dot com slash you right now to get your
first refill
free that's your first refill free at
get quip
dot com slash y o u spelled
g e t q u i p dot
slash y o u quip
better oral health made simple and
rewarding
but you said something a few times
i don't know if it scared me but i don't
know it's it's it's interesting
there's a parallel here with me and you
where you said you took a couple years
off
now for me similar
i mean you know i i i just i i don't
know what
may be midlife crisis whatever i had a
career i'm doing things i'm acting
uh it wasn't like people stopped calling
stop knocking i just was like
i need a break from this i don't know i
just i was a lead on this show called
impastor for two years and
i got good reviews and got two seasons
and it was fun and then after that i was
like you know what
i always wanted to try stand up so i did
six months to stand up and then i go you
know what i want to make a band i've
always wanted to play music
i just really do i love music i mean i
might not be the best singer but i want
to play make a cd
and all of a sudden these things and
then in the podcast some at first
somebody said hey you want to you should
do a podcast you got a good voice i'm
like oh is that the old joke you got a
good
face for radio he's like no you know
it's like uh and i go you know what i'll
try it but not thinking of what i wanted
to do it for but just like i'll make
some money
then i realized wait a minute this is
hard and then i started to open up and
be vulnerable and real
and talk to my guests like and and say
[ __ ] so they open up like
my dysfunction my and so when you're
talking about you know and it's been
about two and a half years
and so you know my agent's like dude you
want you want to stay relevant you want
to stay and i kind of go
and maybe it's cocky i don't know maybe
i shouldn't be but i'm like
i i just feel like i i know um i know
what i
can do i know my abilities i know i
could act but i just didn't feel like it
for a while
and you know you don't want to miss them
you think that had something to do what
age did you start acting like
i mean i did a play in high school and
then i um that
we'll see all my listeners have heard
this but when i did that play
it was the first i was a loser in high
school i mean anybody could tell you i
was the shortest kid
and then when i did that play popular
kid was like down the hallway the next
day
hey man you were really funny in that
i'm like oh my god so not being me is
the way to go and a lot of actors think
about that and
that's how that happens so but i wasn't
getting attention at home or anything
but this is the only attention i got was
at or you know just getting instant so
a response applause and so that i think
that's what happened with my life was
like i just needed that
i didn't know what the other thing was
of real life being fulfilled
all i thought was i guess i just got to
make people like me i guess i got to
just be funny
i got to be on and then all of a sudden
it got me to places
so i thought well that's the right way
to do it and then sometimes
well what happens is at some point in
your life
you go you look in the mirror and i've
done this and i go i don't know who you
are
i don't know who the [ __ ] you are i
remember saying it i don't have that one
as much as this is the one i have my
wife hates it because i tell her about
it all the time
usually it's like two three in the
morning and i'm leaving my office which
is one end of the hallway and i go to my
bedroom which is the other end of the
hallway
and my wife jennifer we've been together
21 years
so we have a lot of memories and [ __ ] as
you walk around the house you know she
every it's she calls a family wall it's
just you know [ __ ] our lives
writ large across this wall and it's a
lot of pictures of me with jen
and our daughter harley jen's parents
who live with us as well
and every once in a while when i'm
leaving my office two three in the
morning heading into my bedroom and [ __ ]
stop and look at it all take it all in
and and at first i'm like this is
wonderful what a wonderful life
and then there's this moment of
disconnect where i'm like who are these
people because like i
i i don't live with anyone that i grew
up with
like like i spent i'm surrounded by four
individuals that i did not know
up until the time i was like 29 years
old and now i've known them all
ever since and one of them came out of
my body partly and [ __ ] like that
but there's a weird disconnect like i've
never had like who are you i've
that's the one thing i've been blessed
with i you know i i've
hung around with people who know who the
[ __ ] they are because that rubs off on
me so i can figure out who the [ __ ] i am
but but many times
i look at the life it's very david byrne
talking heads once in a lifetime which
is like this is not your beautiful house
this is not my beautiful wife and you
may ask yourself
right so i know the feeling but wait a
second so when did you get what year
how old were you when you got small bill
well i'm small but probably got 26 but
and by the way this is therapy this is
what always becomes it becomes therapy
for me the guest
listeners whatever but by the way to
tell you i've always surrounded myself
in fact
any girl i've ever dated says i think
they date me because my friends they're
so grounded they're so real
they're just good people so i think
that's what's has saved me my friends
my friends and the people around me and
i feel like it's not that i ever felt
like
you know i feel like i'm a good person i
feel like i do things but i just think i
was like
hey man uh you don't have to always be
on you don't always have to
do these things and you know what just
because your age you're going to make
them happy if you do a tv show
and you're going to make them happy to
do a movie and everybody's happy but
then you got to go to work and do it
so be careful what you're doing and this
is your life and it's not that long
man you should know that i mean two
years ago your life flashed in front of
in front of you which i want to talk
about because i know you've probably
talked about ad nauseam but
there comes a time where you're like hey
man what what does it mean
i know that sounds so cliche but it's
not about what it means it's like
i want to go to bed i want to die and go
i feel like i
lived like i really just loved i loved i
was loved
and and and i don't care what that takes
to get to that point because i just feel
like i'm working on that it doesn't mean
i don't want to act doesn't mean i don't
want to
but right now i'm figuring all that out
this is what i think
in regards to your case was 10 or 11
years on [ __ ] smallville nine
um i did seven seasons and i did 22
episodes a year
and that's a chunk like you know most
people who consume television
you know and happily do it and of course
when the season ends like [ __ ] i wish
there were 10 more episodes they'd watch
it
every week if they could there are shows
that i would watch
every [ __ ] week i wish it would never
end [ __ ]
but what a lot of people consume media
don't realize is like
all those people yes they have jobs and
they're great jobs nobody complaining
money is great
but it's like you live your life in a
cement block
like you know who really crystallized it
for me was
um lost you know carlos from
flash um so we were sitting around
the set one day chit-chatting and he's a
very introspective young man
he brought up like when does one
stop this sort of thing not like he
don't want to be there but he's just
like
i like i gave up my 20s he's like by the
time this is all said and done
i will have spent my 20s up here in
vancouver
pretending you know to be somebody else
and
i love the people i work with they're
wonderful but he's going i'm never going
gonna get my
20s back like wow and i was like
wow because all i ever have is jason
muse in my ear who forever has always
grassed has greenered it and i'm sure
he's done it to you where he's just like
if i was on a [ __ ] small bill or a cw
show i would he would be one of the
supernatural kids like ride or die
for [ __ ] 28 seasons he'd never [ __ ]
he'd never be like i gotta find myself
he'd never be like who am i he'd be like
i know who i am
i'm the guy on the cw show so his
mindset like i always used to co-sign
when he'd be like
somebody you'd read about somebody
leaving a t-shirt a tv show like when
david caruso
[ __ ] off from [ __ ] you know that tv
show and people were like wow man
why would he do that jason same thing
was always like why would people
like do that but now after
you know as long as i've worked on my
own ship but really having gone up and
worked on a few
cw shows in vancouver like i go
and i'm there for like a month like four
three four weeks with prep and [ __ ] like
that
and then when i get back to my world i'm
like jesus like the world has gone on
without me for a month these kids man
like melissa been up in vancouver since
season two
and like history in america going on
down here
the whole time right right and she's
kind of not a part of it because she's
in a big cement building but now in her
instance
she meant love her life and and so
there's like a happy
more than just like oh i had a great job
and people knew i was this person
and i wanted to be an actress and i
became professional actor she found her
love
on that set as well which you know
doesn't happen to everybody
by the way i'll bring it up i remember
it's funny you say that because your
perspective is so different now because
i
i remember many years ago and i read
something where it said you know you
said you're like michael rosenbob's
leave his mother what what the [ __ ] is
it
i mean i remember he he said it and i
was like [ __ ] kevin smith
what the you know and it wasn't like i
missed that i said something who said
what
yeah like years ago i i don't remember
when but i remember when i heard you
know kevin smith
go said you know michael rose's mom's
leaving what the [ __ ] why is he doing
that was he
it wasn't like whatever and i go what
the what the [ __ ]
why isn't kevin smith like me why does
he passion me for leaving smoke and here
but by the way
and i'm not saying you're wrong but i
was going
but i went through a um like a like i've
had back surgery so i was going through
a lot of pain because i was doing stunts
we were doing a lot of our own stunts
and i hurt my back and i i was like i
can't do this anymore
that was the real and i didn't want you
can't tell that to a studio because
they're like whoa liability
but they you know they offered me
another three years and i and i just was
like
you know what i need to just take care
of myself and i need to
and then i got out i had a surgery it
fixed it i then went to uh i got on
another show
for a year then i did another and then i
was starting to feel better but i was
really for seven years
you're right it was my 20s early 30s and
i was grateful we but we were
in vancouver and it was raining all the
time and it's a beautiful place i love
it
but i think psychologically also playing
that character for so long
i did go a little crazy i think i
there's also that
too which is something that like nobody
particularly even myself
ever would have taken into consideration
because you know you're like well he's
yeah he's playing a bad guy i was
playing lex luthor but
seven [ __ ] years of being like hello
clark
and so not me you know i was like in his
straight jackets and
reading soliloquies and [ __ ] i'm like
this is so the op
and tommy used to laugh because he's
like you would just go and like [ __ ]
around [ __ ] around in action and
boom you're going i go because if i'm
serious all the time i will jump off a
[ __ ] roof
i have to laugh i have to be fun that's
how i have to work
aside from mine there must have been a
[ __ ] cacophony oh yeah you i'm just
saying you're the famous one
but was how much did you get
of why the [ __ ] would you leave like who
was the loudest the fan base
um the people in your professional life
like you know agents and [ __ ] like that
or yourself i think obviously yourself
was the loudest voice because you got to
[ __ ] walk
it wasn't that easy of a decision but i
made a decision i felt like
you know there's a there's a lot of
stories you could say certain things
when you're a certain age and you know
that wasn't necessarily the truth but
once you weed through all that you know
you get through all that [ __ ] you go
what was the real reason
and the real reason was i was done i was
physically done i was mentally done
and i just was like yeah i thought i was
just going to do comedy my whole life
and
you know right off the bat i did you
know one sitcom that wasn't great for a
year i wasn't the lead but
then i did a this thing called so i did
a couple of shows and then a movie and
i was a comedy i'm gonna do comedy i'm
gonna be like or i did urban legend i
was up for like
private ryan and things like that
whatever like little you know whatever
and i
felt and then boom catapulted serious
role lex luther
shave your head 10 months a year and i
think it just like it was like wow i
can't believe i'm playing this character
and it just i i wanted a little bit of
escape i wanted to play something
different i wanted to also
like take a break and then just get my
[ __ ] together
and and try to and be funny and try to
like do things that are lighter
something that i would enjoy more as
much as i love the crew i'd imagine on
some level too you're like i just want
to [ __ ] grow my hair
bro you know what's funny i did i would
be like [ __ ] i remember
you know glenn glenn winter yes that's
right i mean that's that's something
when you mention like how they created
the effects before
like when when i joined i joined season
two of the flash
so they had already done seasons
i think that would be season three of
arrow so the berlanti verse had already
been up for a few minutes
and all the people like in the
producers and writing end of the show
like down here
like go out of their way even though all
of them
watched smallville religiously
all of them were like we don't do those
smallville effects man like we're
spending real money
here we're doing real effects and
whatnot you know because we're in the
age of
cg right when i went up there to work on
the shows
everybody who works on all those shows
already worked
and they had they worked their asses off
but imagine then
there's just they're doing you can't
create dust with cgi then
you can we were playing with tech that
people from
smallville built there was a guy who
like read one episode where somebody had
to punch through a [ __ ] door and he's
like uh
he's like you like this because i was
like i've never felt this before he's
like we invented this for smallville
and i was like he worked on smallville
too and he's like most of these cats did
bob one of my favorite ads in the world
who worked on bulk flash and i love
bob bob i loved everybody
they they're all family to me it was
like honestly i keep in touch with you
hey bob you worked with bob on
smallville bob
uh a first aid dude's kind of like dry
sense of humor like yeah can we do this
yeah yeah yeah that's right because he
talked about is like when we were on
small but one of my favorite things
about bob was one day we're sitting on
set
and bob is like the perfect a.d man
[ __ ] like
keeps the train running dudes dude too
let you play music and talk and [ __ ]
like that
so at one point i was like bob what'd
you do before all this and [ __ ]
and he goes uh i was in the canadian
army
jumped out of airplanes i was like you
you like because he's such a [ __ ]
singular thinker and his own man oh my
god
i was like [ __ ] you took orders and
he's like that's why i wound up in this
job he's going this job
very much like the military he's like
you take orders from above
and you have to execute things on timely
schedules like that's why we use
military
slang and talk in our business so all
the people that i met while working on
flash and supergirl
came from smallville and they all had a
similar story where they were like
you know when they first got up here to
do the berlanti shows like you know the
first
two seasons of uh of green arrow or
arrow sorry right you know they were
like we're not doing
that smallville [ __ ] no super powers
there's not gonna be any wind gags or
anything
like that they're like this is just
[ __ ] fighting for justice with
arrows
then in season two i believe they
introduced the flash
and once the flash was introduced all
the people on flash are like you know
they they didn't want they came from
arrow as well and they're like nobody
wanted to talk about
air cannons ever because they're like
that's so small built and they're like
now
that's all we do like even arrow uses
the [ __ ] air cannons and stuff like
that
all of the track that was laid by
[ __ ] a decade of people up in
vancouver going
how the [ __ ] are we gonna make this [ __ ]
like they're benefiting from
right now still to this day it's nuts
well look
it was honestly you know i i i hate
when people it's it's like the clerk's
thing it's like you know uh
if you know i'm sure people will say you
know oh what happened is crew after
small but whatever career after
uh chasing amy or clerks when you hit a
home run
and you're on something great you can
only go down
so anything uh compared to usually those
things
it's very very difficult so i look at it
because i'm a lottery winner i'm a
lottery ticket winner
i me i was a part of something that was
brilliant i say that all the time and i
truly mean it the older i get and the
more mature which is not easy for me
that maturity comes just with experience
it's not even whether you want to be
mature or not
you live a long enough life you have no
choice
i mean obviously we could think of very
public examples but it's not true but it
seems like the older one gets
you have no choice to get mature so of
course like i loved what you said before
about like
getting way past it and then looking
back and having a different
perspective when you were like why did i
really do that
yeah i've had that moment many times in
my life where you do the thing in the
moment
and then you have to kind of recollect
somewhere down the road when you when
you're
free of the blast and everything is
where it needs to be in the present
why did i really do that what was the
reason behind that i want to get like
you are where you could honestly go
you know get to the level where because
for me it's like it's like uh
it's the be-all end-all at times like i
you know this has to be
i have to be great i have to my peers
have to you know i have to
prove to them i haven't so i'm getting
past that but i want to aspire like you
said
where you can go i want to go make this
movie because it's funny because
i'm the biggest horror fan there is i
mean i i mean you'd love it i'm just
saying i say that because i really love
i watch three horror movies a week and
um i i
i'm writing a horror series that we're
pitching and i have like this horror
movie that came up and i pitched my
agent a couple producing friends and
they're like did you have to make that
because you could either go and you
could uh go pitch it and you'll have no
control
or you can go which scares me too i
don't need to have all control i just
like i want to go shoot with my friends
you came to a point where you're like
hey
i want to do this movie where i could
shoot for 300
000 where at the end of the day i want
to have fun and if we make something
great
awesome let's try and let's enjoy it but
i don't want to kill myself doing it
and if it's a success if even if it's
not a success it's still a success
because you made a 300 000
movie so you've gotten to a point where
you can actually go let's go make that
and there's no pressure
and i really want that to be like the
next thing
all you have to do is realize i mean
this is gonna sound so simplistic but
it's like
the moment you make a thing you've won
like the end results everything else is
just
gravy everything else is scenery and
stuff like that
everything else are asterisks and minor
statistics but like the moment you
create a thing that is yours
or aid in creating a thing that you know
bringing art to life bringing something
to life
that wasn't there before creation rather
than destruction you win
like it's that simple um then there are
degrees of like you know
how how many people know about it that's
that's really
and of course money that's associated i
guess with money
um the more people know about it some
assume
the more money there is to it but those
of us in podcasting know that that's
really not the case at all
do you hear that patrons you can have
numbers out the wazoo man but what i
found
like what what podcasting for me was
incredible for
was number one just self-expression like
because i was like always like oh man a
great job would be a radio
show host it'd be amazing to be howard
stern and [ __ ]
and then one day somebody was like you
can do a podcast and i'm like
why like the ricky gervais podcast that
happened and scott mosher was talking
about he listened to it he's like it's
funny they sit around they just talk to
each other he's kind of like what we do
on a commentary track
i said then we should make one of these
podcasts and still to this dab i've
never listened to the ricky gervais
podcast but it's the origin point
of everything i do because i was like
well ricky gerais is funny he's just
sitting around talking to his [ __ ]
friends that sounds like a good life
that sounds kind of like what howard
stern does and so then you tried on and
you're like oh
this is rapturous because it's
free self-expression not like i've got
an idea and i need to self-express give
me 20 million dollars in ben affleck
it's like hey man sit down we're gonna
have a conversation and you could
showcase people who aren't [ __ ] stars
you could showcase people who don't
normally get showcased like
that's awesome smartcast for me was like
ladies and gentlemen here's scott moser
the guy who produces all my movies who i
think is [ __ ] funnier than me we're
gonna have this ongoing conversation
um here's j smews ladies and gentlemen
you know him from those movies but the
real guy
way funnier than the [ __ ] character
here he is here's my wife here's my kid
like
showcasing it's fulfilling too yes and
you get to put those people up on
pedestal and then people
understand about you as an artist a
little more like oh i can see where
that person is an influence and stuff
like that it's because there's no money
it's the sky is the limit so the one
that's the thing that
always [ __ ] with the dream the ambition
and [ __ ] is
money um the moment you can learn to
ameliorate that
then the sky's the limit so you just
have to be able
to pivot and pivot [ __ ] hard so you
go into a place and you're like
we need five million dollars to make
this movie and they're like absolutely
not
nobody wants to give you five [ __ ]
million dollars you got a choice
either that [ __ ] script sits in a
drawer and you wonder if it ever would
have worked
or you [ __ ] change your tactic in my
case
as the guy who made the [ __ ] first
movie was 27 000 bucks
and then i my career came from that one
dopey inexpensive movie
i'm always in favor of like let's roll
the bones with lower budget
because if it works it's the [ __ ]
lottery ticket everybody gets [ __ ]
rich
we all look smart we got a story to tell
about how nobody [ __ ] believed in us
like all of it is graveyard and if it
doesn't work
and that's the detroit the only choice
because either you do that
or the thing don't get made and if the
things don't get made
nothing has accomplished nothing has
occurred like you're just stagnant so
i'd always rather like [ __ ] risk it
on way less money i know like the people
i work with are always frustrated
because the moment they're like
you know the budget is this and i'm like
oh let's just [ __ ]
let's just drop this this this and as a
guy who's editing the movie and as a guy
who's not very visionary and never has
very expensive ideas
even if i have a script like you know we
felt and found this on twilight of the
mall rats movie we're working on right
now
um budget came in probably let's say
a million two over what we wanted it
to be where we all felt comfortable
where it was going to get greenlit and
[ __ ]
you know so they're like what do we do
and in that instance i'm like well
i [ __ ] got us into this trouble by
dreaming up this stupid [ __ ]
let me see if i can back us out of it as
well and you start going through the
script and going like
all right well you don't need this they
don't need to jump through the roof
twice you know once we'll be fine and
that takes off about 50 000 of a stunt
day and
you just chip away at it until you can
get down now in the instance that was an
instance of like
verified breathing where it's like we
gotta bring the movie down by 1.2
million
that intimates that somebody's giving us
millions of dollars to tell a [ __ ]
story
most of the time it's not the case
mostly and when i say millions mine are
always under 10 at this point ain't
nobody giving me
[ __ ] 10 million or more in this world
anymore so
because i can like just reconstruct it
to be cheaper
like that's that's the key man like i
you know my respect
to to chris nolan but like that
you know that's the director who's just
like i in order to [ __ ] do this
sequence we're going to shoot it forward
and then we're going to shoot it
backwards and we're not going to reverse
the film
that's cheap we're going to shoot the
sequence
in reverse because that's a mind [ __ ]
and an accomplishment and what are we
doing in cinema if not trying to push
them i love that good for him and i
[ __ ] can't wait to see it and i
respect filmmakers like that
they're absolutely my betters but i'm
the other guy
i'm the guy that's just like you know
that's good enough good enough has
gotten me
26 almost 27 years into a very unlikely
career
so for me it's like good enough man if
the shot is soft
it's good enough man as long as that
performance is singing
that's what's important it don't have to
look great it don't have to sound great
you don't have to like break dimensions
and barriers and [ __ ] like you know
who you are
that's the simple way to say it you know
who you
are what you can do and i'm you're that
guy
if that's what they want you're not
chris nolan you're kevin smith
this is what i do and you know what
you're gonna get i'm gonna bust my ass
i'm gonna keep it
everybody's gonna have fun no one's
gonna be screamed at you know what it
means too
is that your phone don't ring a lot
um you know i don't get a lot of calls
people go like [ __ ] save us
direct one of these studio movies we
need your help so
you know in a world where i was waiting
for that for that to
practice my craft i'd probably be out of
this game long
[ __ ] time ago and stuff but i've got
the ability to
generate my own material so it's like i
don't have to technically
ever wait for somebody to be like you
may
make your art good sir like now i'm in a
place where i'm like
like if i want to do it we're going to
do it because
none of the [ __ ] i want to do is earth
shattering
it's not me going like we're going to
make star wars on a budget
not at all most of the [ __ ] i want to do
is stupid it's like this stoner talks to
the star
like they did 30 years ago so
inside of you is brought to you by
vincero
watches what's that you got on your
wrist there michael uh
it's a beautiful vincero watch ryan
what's going to say you don't you don't
wear watches
usually exactly and how often have you
seen me wear a watch
i mean a bunch now well right that's
exactly right you know why
because it doesn't look it looks cool
and it's not
i don't like flashy but i want a solid
watch
what i love about this watch guys is
it's not
expensive it's you're getting a solid
quality good-looking watch and it's
reasonably priced and it's i'm telling
it's so comfortable this band
i don't even know what the hell this
band is it just feels good man we are
partnering with vincero watches i'm
extremely excited about this
uh to welcome them as a sponsor and uh
you know like we said making a statement
doesn't have to cost a fortune
with vincero you can elevate your look
for an affordable price
and our listeners we're getting 15
percent off guys
15 off vincero off your entire order
then cerro is also covering the shipping
cost if you just
visit vincero vincerowatches.com
y o u v i n c e r o watches
dot com slash y o u it's a really unique
design
and uh you won't find it anywhere else
they have over 23
thousand five star reviews i don't have
that many
for inside of you i might have eight
thousand five star reviews that's a lot
and we're a five star
yeah but these guys have twenty three
thousand five star reviews so
i don't even need to tell you this but
uh free shipping
free returns for 30 days and a warranty
on your watch for up to two years pretty
wild pretty awesome
and uh stress free shopping right from
home so you need to do it
yeah it's a great gift it's a great you
know you're gonna see me wearing the
heck out of this
whether i'm on my stages playing music
in guitar because uh it's just cool
exclusive discount 15 off entire
purchase 15
off your entire order only for our
listeners we cover all
shipping costs go to vincerowatches.com
you promo code y o
u it's that easy it's a buy you won't
regret
i mean this is awesome i could talk to
you forever you know the only time
you've ever really
talked we were at in england at a con
and you took me aside you go dude you're
playing martin x i'm like ah it's a
small role
you know that's me and you're like yeah
but it's like it's one of the original
you knew everything and i wish i knew
something to tell him
you know but you're going to be in the
sequel right i go i i don't know i don't
know what's
but it was so nice you to kind of you
know take me aside and it was just like
i never met you know i was just like i
like this guy i never met him
and uh it was just like when you meet
somebody there you just have a warmness
to you that i was like
i want to work with that guy he just he
makes me feel confident
i honestly thank you that means the
world and stuff and aside from just
liking your professional work
i always [ __ ] enjoyed you through
jason muse
who is like you you should be paying him
like publicity i love him
what is he going to do he sings your
praise i mean again he loved that show
and if he could like if if you guys
could still be [ __ ] clark and lex
i bet you'd pay you to do it
oh man hey by the way and he loved the
show itself but he loved your dynamics
he's like they're so good dude they
treat it so
seriously man it's just like [ __ ]
reading the comics and [ __ ] you know
what i was like yeah
superman suit and he goes in that way
it's not like the comics no
but you know what i gotta say um thank
god social media wasn't around and thank
god
it was just i i didn't watch anything i
wasn't a huge comic book fan like i said
i'm a
i'm a horror fan so for me people always
ask the question i'm like i got to be
honest with you i just
i wanted to learn my lines and they were
good lines and and just be believable
and and grow and show emotion and just
be real and let the
writers and the and the directors kind
of you know and that's it i just didn't
i go i'm not going to try and emulate
i'm not going to try and be real
fun i just wanted to be real that's it
just be
real let me ask you some inside baseball
about vancouver you did you stay at the
sutton for seasons one and two
sutton place season one i got a
houseboat season two on uh
the [ __ ] seriously as a houseboat yeah
it was awesome
colorful [ __ ] that's awesome it
was awesome houseboat and then i lived
in
no other cw kids do that i don't know if
it was the best thing you'd ever do you
wake up and there's a seal at your back
door i'm not [ __ ] kidding a seal
right he's right i mean he ain't right
he ain't wrong kids it got [ __ ] silly
it was it was awesome but you know
what's genius about that being on a
[ __ ] series and living on a houseboat
like number one you're gonna get rocks
to sleep every night so that's kind of
awesome yeah
there's something pastoral and serene
about being at one with the sea
but you don't need that much space in
your world like having an apartment or a
house because what do you do
you [ __ ] wake up get in a car
go to the [ __ ] stage and you're there
for the next 15 [ __ ] hours and then
you get to come home and cry
and i'm sure if there were days where
you're like [ __ ] i just want to sleep in
a goddamn hotel
you could just walk across the street
stay in the goddamn room and i was a
regular
i was a regular at the aquarium i mean
they knew me
behind the scenes brought everybody i
knew the ins and outs i'd donate to them
whatever it was all right how many
seasons were you on the boat oh just one
i should have kept it
i remember the dick the dick owls owned
it the dickhouse
that was that that was their name i was
gonna ask you because you said jason
muse
and it brought me up a question you know
an idea when he was talking
in the interview it was so good and he
brought up when he was
you know going through the addiction it
was like one of the last times he said
you were sitting in the car picking him
up and he started to walk towards you
and you didn't even recognize him and
that was the first time he saw you cry
you cried and that's and it just
i remember i almost lost it because it
was so emotional i'm like
just i mean to be fair he was right that
was the first time he saw me cry
uh but now we're up to like a thousandth
why is that everyone gets and when i
became a stoner in like 2008
like i started wearing my heart on my
sleeve and everything [ __ ] touched me
that's how i even wound up
directing the flash because i was just
watching the flash and i shot a video of
me [ __ ] like
balling crying at how good it was and so
my agent was like
you know well i actually was jason's
wife jordan she was like i called
you boy jordan who's my agent and said
call
[ __ ] somebody in flash and see if you
know maybe they'll let him direct an
episode he loves the show so much
and i was so mad at i was like don't
[ __ ] do that i don't need no help
from the shirtless boy network
we're doing fine over here and [ __ ] like
that and then when they said
oh we'd love you to come i was like
thank god you said that oh my god we're
gonna go
up and direct the flash and [ __ ] you
always you work with people all the time
where you like
you have uh people that you work with
again and again
is that because not only they're
talented but a lot of it has to do with
comfort
absolutely like i know what they're
capable of
and you know sometimes you're like why
am i just gonna like
elevate some stranger particularly the
same [ __ ] stranger that everybody
picks for like 50 movies a year
when i can elevate somebody nobody's
seen like when i wrote
chasing amy um i we were looking for
three million dollars to make the movie
and you know we just set up an overall
deal of miramax and stuff
and so you know i was like uh i wrote
this for
ben affleck and joey adams and jason lee
um and you know the people i've worked
with on [ __ ] mall rats i met
all three of them on all rats but
they're capable of so much more and
level
so at merrell poster who's our executive
mirror max lovely person
she was like no we're not gonna give you
three million dollars to make a movie
with people nobody have ever heard of
and i was like what do you mean like
well we we have people we would like
this good script
we have people in deals that we'd like
to put into the movie and i was like oh
well who and they were like uh we're
thinking
david schwimmer um drew barrymore
and a young up-and-coming comic who
hadn't
hadn't had the daily show yet jon
stewart
so you know i'm like all right well i
get it
and i know they're famous or whatever
the [ __ ] but
you know i i wrote this for these three
people
and i think they're really like [ __ ]
talented and people aren't
overly familiar with their work like no
disrespect to drew barrymore but like
she
particularly at that point she got all
the jobs like
she needs another one you know it's like
this person like number one i wrote the
character bait
this person but number two it's like how
about we introduce somebody
like [ __ ] new and [ __ ] like that so
you know once in that instance i dropped
the budget down to like
that was one of those one of the first
movies i had to pivot on where we wanted
three
million and they were like not with that
cast no way
um our cast three million your cast
we're not making the movie
so i offered to make the movie for 200
grand with my cast
and i was like we'll make the movie uh
if you guys like it
it's yours if not you give it to us we
get to sell it someplace else
and they give us 250 grand we went off
and made the [ __ ] movie so it's
another case of like
just [ __ ] shrink the budget [ __ ] it
man like we'll just
do it by hook or by crook but i'd rather
you know
stick with someone that i know or i
believe in
or you know i mean let's say i went with
their version of chasing amy and [ __ ]
like you know obviously we all love jon
stewart now
david schwimmer beloved from friends and
stuff and drew barrymore no slouch
whatsoever
got to imagine it might have gotten
attention maybe even more attention
because those people
a little more famous or whatever the
[ __ ] so
it's not like that would have been the
worst version of [ __ ] chasing game it
was just not the one i had
in my head and because i stuck with like
the version i wanted to make and you
know it wasn't like
i'm implacable you give me three million
or like i
[ __ ] bent hard where i was like look
give me three million for the movie like
no i'm like
i'll suck your dick you know like i
dropped right down into the basement
with like give me 200 000
so in that instance i'm obviously
amenable when it comes to the budget
[ __ ] i was not amenable
when it came to the cast to the muses
not jason muse but the people who
inspired the movie like
ben was holden mcneil joey was
like uh alyssa jones and stuff and jason
lee i'd seen him he'd been in mall rats
with us but i saw him in my friend
malcolm's movie give this amazing
performance
a movie called drawing flies and i was
like oh my god i'm under utilizing this
this kid so i wrote him a much meatier
part and chase gave me where he got to
be funny and he got to be like you know
like he got to act as well so how was
our reward for that
ben affleck became a major movie star
and for a [ __ ] good long stretch of
my career
it's pretty easy for me to get movies
made because i'd be like
well i'm in it and j muse and well
ben's coming you know and they'd be like
here's the [ __ ] money
same thing with jason lee jason lee went
on to become a [ __ ] movie intake tv
star
um and joey she got the golden globe
nomination for chasing amy so like
it's it was worthwhile it wasn't just
like you know i'm pigheaded and i want
my way
i was willing to drop the budget to do
what we did and
it never occurred to me to like trade
up i see a lot of directors i'm not like
[ __ ] on anybody but
i always see directors who like seem to
work with whoever's hot
like at the [ __ ] moment and stuff
nothing wrong with that's [ __ ] good
business and [ __ ] everyone loves movie
star
like ron howard's that kind of guy like
whoever's hot at the moment
right like for a long stretch of time he
was in the ron howard's next movie or
something like that
i i'm just never it's not you
i'm not a heat seeker my heat i seek
is more like now i know how to write for
this
for this chair in the orchestra like i
know how this
[ __ ] plays so i can really
[ __ ] put a piece together compose a
piece and conduct a piece that's gonna
sound like [ __ ] magic man now you
know
yes if i put eddie van halen in that
chair everyone's gonna be like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's eddie van halen
but just because this guy ain't had a
van helen don't mean that they're not
gonna [ __ ] shred
this stuff that's brilliant um let me
all right this is rapid fire we're just
kidding this is honestly these are quick
it's luck well it's got you know you
know hey
you know rap it's rapid fire it's called
[ __ ] talking with kevin smith these are
like from my patrons they're
awesome they're just so supportive of
the podcast they're asking some
questions so honestly you could just be
simple because you you've probably heard
some questions so you
i i just rapid fire kev yeah
he's got to chase he's got to make his
hat he's got a face he's got
the speed at which these questions are
coming he's got to get there he wants to
be blown up
uh all right i'm just going to fire him
off lisa h rumor has it all rats 2
script has been written can you give any
details on the plot
yeah the plot is uh it takes place in
the present post coven
coven's part of it it would have to be
um
brody bruce uh dealing with the
death of maul culture the original mall
rat himself
facing his own mortality along with the
mortality of the [ __ ]
ball the thing he loves most in life um
going on an adventure
with his uh teenage daughter i like that
all right james r which superhero have
you connected with the most and why
batman for sure i don't know why because
i'm not rich and i've never
honed my body to physical perfection and
stuff and my parents like well my dad's
dead but my parents were never killed in
an alley my mom's still alive
um but you know he's so romantic um on
some level the idea of
unlike superman who is a god from
another planet you know um
or unlike spider-man who's bitten by a
radioactive spider
you know batman is the achievable you
need a lot of money and you need a lot
of time and a lot of emo
but you know it's just a guy out there
you know
trying to [ __ ] make a difference or
whatever so i've always loved
that story even going back to childhood
adam west was you know my first batman
um and and and the neil adams detective
cover with batman crucified
uh joker holding that giant car that was
like one of my first comic books so
batman's been in my dna
forever even though i don't identify
with him one iota well
also batman the animated series which i
was voice i voiced a few things in
that's how harley quinn
your daughter was named harley because
of that i mean the animations i played a
bunch of characters and i loved it
andrea romano directed what i loved her
bruce tim
mikey what's been your favorite part
about working with your daughter in
movies
um you know my favorite part about
working with a kid is just like
um you get a second bite at the apple to
make pretend with your kid
you know because at a certain point kid
grows up and you can't be like hey man
let's [ __ ] play
dolls like you missed that window that
window closed and
you know we played all throughout her
childhood like
luckily i had a job that afforded me a
lot of [ __ ] time around my kid as she
grew up and stuff
but at the same time you know
bittersweet at a certain point
it ends like i always talk about this
one story with her where like i remember
we were playing hide and go seek
in my bedroom and you know there's only
like [ __ ]
three places at best to hide and we've
been playing it for over 20 rounds
and she was like again and i was like oh
kiddo there's nowhere left to
hide man why don't you go see nana pop
for a little while and stuff
and um you know she did you know she
went off to see her
her grandparents are downstairs at the
house i remember like
feeling like hearing harry chapin
carpenter in my [ __ ] ears singing
about the cats and the cradle and [ __ ]
oh
forget it like you know your kid wanted
to [ __ ] play with you i thought about
it as she got older i was like there's
that one
day where i was like oh kiddo like go
cnn pop
we'll play hide and seek tomorrow we
never played hide and seek again and i
blinked and the kid was
beyond the age if i didn't see so you
know i felt like wow i [ __ ] up
like even though that song existed and
[ __ ] you know i fell prey to the
[ __ ] like sooner or later
uh you know you're just like oh this
time later and time [ __ ]
up girl was just like me don't make me
[ __ ] cry though you're gonna make me
cry
but the thing is being on sat with her
makes up for that like suddenly i'm an
adult she's an adult but we are making
pretend it is like
she's a kid again where it's like oh you
stand here and [ __ ] say this i'm
gonna stand here
well i'm not gonna say anything but like
and jay is going to be this guy go
that's cool yeah that's [ __ ] cool man
carly chasing me was a beautiful love
letter to being young and
in love and the endless possibilities of
and fluidity of romance have you ever
considered revisiting the topic with
characters in their
30s or 40s um
no no because chasing amy was i love
chasing him this wonderful movie
but i had to go through painful [ __ ]
[ __ ]
to make chasing amy you were dating
lauren
yeah joey lauren adams yeah we were
dating that's kind of the movie's kind
of based like a little bit on our
relationship
some degree was it hard uh dating
someone who's the lead actress in your
movie
no it was wonderful um i think
it got hard after the movie came out um
because you know suddenly we were
every piece of press we were doing was
together and you know the story was just
like
the director and his girlfriend the star
of the movie and stuff
and you know for me that's great uh for
joey you know i'm sure she at a certain
point as much as she
i know she loves chase gaming love the
role and stuff but you know
she didn't come to this business to be
an appendage
you know what i'm saying like chasing
amy was even though
she got nominated for a golden globe and
[ __ ] like that
you know it was i i got a lot of
attention for the movie because it was
it had a nice little comeback story to
it like maul rats was
should have killed them but oh [ __ ] who
knew we had this cinnamon stuff
so that played a part i remember like
joey
told me like she went to a meeting at
icm
um and the agent she met with
was like are you still dating
kevin smith and she's like yeah and he's
like how long do you think that's gonna
last after this
she's like what do you mean he's like
and
you know i remember she came home from
that meeting she told me i was like
number one
[ __ ] icm don't be rep there um
but number two dude wasn't wrong
like we wound up breaking up shortly
thereafter and stuff like that
um so i always say that our relationship
was sacrificed on the altar of
chasing amy we had a cool little
relationship but then it became
fodder for the movie which you know i
i never regret because it was for her
you know i was of course you know
i head over heels for joey and joey's
dream was to be
taken seriously as an actress she was
her first role was you know she was the
girl who took bud bundy's virginity on
on married with children and she was
like super tight with parker posey and
parker posey the year before had done
um party girl and like [ __ ] broke
huge and every
you know every magazine newspaper wrote
about her she was like the girl of the
year and stuff
and you know that's what joey came out
to be and stuff
and so you know we were in a
relationship
and there's a line in that dire strait
song romeo and juliet where mark
knopfler sings i
i dreamed your dream for you so now your
dream is real
whenever i hear that i always think
about joey and chasing amy's that was
her
dream and like you know i was like all
right i'll [ __ ] dream your dream for
you
and it became [ __ ] real so
it was you know it was beautiful like
everything that i've no only positive
things came out of
dating joey including the movie itself
chasing amy but
since the movie became the basis for the
stuff in the movie
it was a little too close to the surface
and
you know just eventually [ __ ] broke down
pretty you know not too far let me see
january
of 97 we were at sundance
with chasing amy in april of 97 it came
out in theaters
and then we broke up in july a few
months later and stuff and we had dated
for like a total of two years but
you know i can never feel regret about
the relationship
ending you know i'm in a marriage and
i've been married for years and happy
and she's in a marriage she happened to
but more importantly that little
snapshot of our entire
[ __ ] relationship and the dynamic
because i was very much like holden very
like jealous and [ __ ]
um is preserved like you know
and and it also gave both of our careers
like an incredible boost and stuff i'm
so
yeah well i'm so glad when i said rapid
fire that for that question
you [ __ ] no i am i am because if you
would a rapid fire
that because that was beautiful that's a
beautiful it's like this
it just will live forever you know that
moment's a moment in time it's a
beautiful thing it's just i'm glad
thank you for that last one jason w
kevin i wanted you to know your heart
attack motivated me to see my doctor as
i had been sick for about three months i
changed my diet began exercising by june
july of 2018 i no longer had congestive
heart failure
thank you brother for being my
motivation to make
changes that [ __ ] rocks i mean the
heart attack
the many good things that came out of
the heart attack one of which was like
i went vegan and wound up dropping a
bunch of weight and [ __ ] my
cholesterol dropped and then
like you know i'm truly i'm not in great
shape but i'm in better shape than i've
been
like almost my entire [ __ ] life um
that was a positive that came out of it
the perspective
once that happens you're like now you
don't i don't wait for anything now it's
like we ain't got time we gotta go
because [ __ ] tomorrow i might drop
that and [ __ ]
um but the side benefit
has been you know because you go out
there and tell the story and stuff and i
was i was on like colbert told the story
a bunch of talk shows and whatnot
um and the story gets out there
and people like aside from like you know
entertaining people for a bit and it's a
good
story because you know if i'm telling it
it means it ended
well right um but the wonderful thing
has been
so many people and i mean an incredible
amount of people over the course of the
last two and a half years
have told me a very similar sentiment
where they were like your [ __ ]
scare the [ __ ] out of me and because
you're not much
older or younger than me or i look
exactly like you
or [ __ ] i live exactly like you eat
the same [ __ ]
i'm sedentary i'm like you i don't
[ __ ] work out
whatever those cats saw it as a
wake-up call like which is incredible
because
i you know for years people haven't been
telling me do something about your
weight or whatever
my wake-up call was literally like you
know i was this [ __ ] close to
dropping dead
so it's nice that people out there took
my wake-up call
as their wake-up call so when i hear
that like
i like you know i i don't really have
existential moments and stuff other than
when i'm like who are these people when
i look at the frame pictures on the wall
hey hold on shut up thank you
i hear that all the time don't worry um
you always wonder
like you know i know i served myself in
this life you know clerks is [ __ ]
like
that not a day has gone by since 1993
that i haven't said the word clerks and
stuff um
everything kind of worked out
professionally even personally things
worked out and stuff
but you wonder like you know if i wasn't
here
did the world benefit would it have
changed and because of like aside from
the movies people are like oh yeah i
like those movies without you that would
have been a clerk's like never mind that
me having a heart attack and talking
about it like
made a lot of people [ __ ] like
themselves and literally
saved their lives so you know at the end
of the day like i felt like right on
[ __ ] whatever else i did like you know
when was i ever gonna save a [ __ ]
life you know what i'm saying like i
ain't batman
and yet in that way of going like hey i
almost died here's a funny story
but you should [ __ ] take it seriously
because i'm not that old and i almost
[ __ ] dropped it
because that a bunch of [ __ ]
are above ground today that makes me
feel
buddy i mean that's what i mean this
show it's like just little things like
not
big things like that but when you say
when you tell your story it's just it's
amazing how
i had no idea the impact like just
whoever listens
when they hear that story it might just
give them a boost to be like hey
you know it's that's it when you see
somebody who has so much fame so much
success and
well you're self-deprecating so you'll
talk about the bombs as well
but like you see that and you're like
death will go it kills
it goes after anyone it doesn't matter
who the [ __ ] you are he's successful
he's shooting a movie he's doing
something at a cl
and he's gone lemner redstone just
passed away
uh you know made it into his 90s but
like sumner redstone controlled
paramount viacom at one point one of the
richest men in the world a
multi-multi-billionaire and stuff
it don't stop the inevitable like you
can't buy off death or anything like
that
so take care of yourselves he sure
certainly did
he made it well into his [ __ ] 90s but
take care of yourself
it's always worth spending an extra buck
or two to look in on your health because
you know i know it's tough financially
in the world
and sometimes you got to figure out
whether to pay [ __ ] rent or
food but neither of those things matter
anymore if
you check out so always take the extra
buck if you have to
spend it on yourself man like you do for
so many people in this [ __ ] world
you do for your parents you do for your
boyfriend girlfriend you do for your
kids you do for strangers you do for
friends
do for yourself look in on your your own
health just make sure everything's okay
cause you never [ __ ]
did you're glorious i i can't thank you
enough for your time
and uh your insight it has been absolute
fun we can do it again anytime you want
well i'm gonna hold you that now come on
[ __ ] podcasts we don't do pictures
dude i'll do whatever you want come on
when i'm done i'm around you tell me
that when i get to interview you the
whole time
i love that you can ask me anything i
get i can get deep sweet
dude all my love all my health love to
your family be safe
thanks for coming on and give my love to
jason i will pass it on man thank you
excellent talking to you it was a great
time you too man that was awesome
just a good guy right just a really nice
guy had a lot to say
had a lot to say that it was one of the
episodes where
uh and you know me i'm a yapper i
i didn't yet much no it's sort of like
uh let the man who knows what he's
talking about
he just goes let him go he has a lot to
say he's interesting
he's very smart he's incredibly humble
he's got great stories
let him go it was easy for me i just sat
back and go yeah dude
great i love this keep talking it's
easier for me too
it sure is are you what are you saying
[ __ ]
it's easier for me when you shut the
[ __ ] up rosenbaum sorry for the f-bombs
i normally don't do as many f-bombs but
i did some
f-bombs also make sure if you if you
really love the podcast
and you're a fan uh you want to support
it even more
we have the lovely patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n
you go to patreon.com inside
i've got a wonderful community there's
so many people there have become friends
uh there's message boards there's uh
inside of me where you ask me questions
there's
and i dress up as another character
asking me the questions um
there are [ __ ] talking where certain
tiers get to ask the guest questions
there's uh live youtubes or you know we
just have a little concert on a sunday
tons of fun stuff for patreons and it's
a great family and i think you'll really
enjoy it
and if you want to uh support the show
in an extra way
great if not just you listening is
enough uh once again thanks for
listening and please subscribe
if you liked the podcast if you enjoyed
it please subscribe tell all your
friends email them
tweet instagram our handles are at in
inside of you podcast
on the instagram and facebook at
insideofup on twitter
uh if you want to leave me a message i
check them every couple of months
because i don't have a big team here to
help me but
uh hello at inside of you podcast you
could leave messages i'll eventually get
to them whether i get back to you
it just depends if you're saying hey
love the show you know
if you have a two-page email to me you
know it's not going to be you know it's
hard to read two-page emails
it's like just try to say it in a in a
paragraph how about how about a sentence
is that a lot i mean i know look people
write letters and i read them and i love
them
but sometimes you know these message
boards it's just easier if it's
i have a dd it's okay to edit some posts
yeah
write your feelings and then you know
right let the english teacher and you
guide you
that's right and i don't remember
english class uh remember the inside of
you online store uh
fifteen percent off if you use the code
rosie pants r-o-s-e-y
pants p-a-n-t-s rosy pants one
fifteen percent off um brand new
tumblers that are badass and
flip-flops and mugs and autographed mugs
and
beach towels i've given ryan most of
this [ __ ] uh and don't forget to stage
it
october 24th it's coming up in just a
few days
and that is halloween time so that's
gonna be a lot of fun rob and i are
dressing up we're gonna play music and
some
covers and originals and uh there's
prizes you win zooms and
a bunch of other shits so join us on
stage it go to stagert.com
and just type in rosenbaum and dance and
d-a-n-s-o-n and you'll see two shows
pacific standard time uh let's give a
little bit of love to
uh the people who deserve some more love
and that's my patrons
and uh i love saying their names nancy d
mary b leah s trisha sarah v little lisa
little lisa you kiko hello you might i
gotta bring that character back to the
patreon
hello it might so this bite you haven't
seen that one yet have you
all right i gotta show you that one jill
e brian h where have you been brian h
man i haven't talked to you in a while i
know you uh
walked into a store in um azusa my buddy
at uh chaos records you walked in with
an inside of you shirt and a hat and a
mask and i was like yeah he's like hey
your buddy's here
lauren g nico angelina g lee robin asked
jerry w
jerry how's the movie emily bobby robert
i jason w stephen j
kristen k not to be confused with
kristen crook
amelia o allison l jess j lucas m
raj raj where are your raj raj
raj want to stage it he uh he was the
big bitter
top bidder on stage so he had a bunch of
[ __ ] but he gave a lot of his [ __ ] to
marissa
and another patron part of the team
rogue flash thing you don't know that
that's an
inside joshua d emily s cjp samantha
m humza b jennifer n
jackie p stacy l carly h jennifer s
janelle b
carrie beat tab with the 272 not to be
confused with tap with the 273
yeah kimberly e crystal h mike e marissa
nanirello ramirez beth b
santiago m sarah f chad w leanne p
russian w rey a maya p maya p
megan j matty s tiffany i kendrick f
ashley e
margie m thomas t matt w belinda and
benjamin
r lisa j kevin v robert s james r chris
h snow r sean v anusha w
oshborn h dave h spider-man chase
sheila g jacob h misha h
william h the new patrons thank you for
joining
thank you to everybody this is uh i hope
you had a good time listening to this
podcast
and listening to kevin smith and next
week's a huge episode so
please tune in thank you for allowing me
to be inside of each and every one of
you from uh
my house in in undisclosed location
undisclosed hollywood hills location
along with my
engineer friend slash
editor extraordinaire
uh ryan me
see you guys